on se couche tôt vous venez tout juste
d'arriver en russie vous voyez l'intérêt
que votre visite suscite
parlez-nous votre mission les bien
précises elle est extrêmement rare de
protection avec ces baleines
elle nous un peu de ce qu'ils allaient
faire là bas notre mission pour
l'instant c'est d'une part de nous
associer notre équipe avec l'équipe qui
étaient à s'occuper
les baleines sont en prison actuellement
pour voir dans quelle mesure on peut les
aider
on n'est pas là pour critiquer on est là
pour aider on a beaucoup d'expérience
ailleurs mais ces gens qui sont ici ont
la responsabilité ces animaux en
captivité
donc on est là pour les aider voir dans
quelle mesure à peu près un certain
temps au pouvoir les relâcher
s'il veut ultime de votre mission est
l'objectif de leur état on a beaucoup
étudié ce qui a été produit par les
scientifiques et par les gens qui
s'occupent de ces animaux d'une façon
quotidienne
ils sont là bas et c'est pour ça qu'on
veut aller les voir pour les rencontrer
pour voir leur parler mais c'est juste
le début d'un travail qui va peut-être
prendre je sais pas des années
éventuellement n'ont absolument pas
cette excuse il faut chaque animal est
un cas particulier et on sait oui grâce
aux gens qui ont des maisons attraper on
sait où ils ont été attrapés et quand
ils seront en état
ils ont récupéré leurs centres etc sont
remis là où ils ont été attrapés
ça peut prendre à mon avis ça doit
pouvoir entrer dans les deux trois ans
qui viennent
elles ont été capturées par heureux dans
des parcs aquatiques les baleines sont
encore la pierre angulaire de ce parc
aquatique
c'est ce qui attire les gens qu'est-ce
que cet épisode unique en russie devra
envoyer comme message aux gouvernements
du monde entier
il y en a beaucoup trop et il y en a il
ya des demandes pour de plus en plus
mais il se trouve qu'aujourd'hui avec ce
que j'appelle la révolution des
communications
il ya de moins en moins de jeunes qui
veulent voir ces animaux en captivité
parce que ils savent que ce sont des
animaux très intelligents qui sont dans
les océans ce que nous sommes sur terre
et il est très important grâce à la
révolution des communications
nous avons aujourd'hui de communiquer
avec tout le public sur la planète en
étant là avec eux dans leur
environnement et ma mission est aussi au
futur c'est très simple c'est de dire si
vous protéger les océans où nous
protéger vos mails